Dude! Why don't we take all that excess nuclear waste to the sun? Why don't we do that?
Hey Earthlings! Welcome to DNews. I'm
Trace. Nuclear waste is
a rough topic. It's part of the reason
people are opposed to nuclear
power. We're getting electricity today, sure,
but we're creating something that could pollute
for centuries. People ain't
onboard with that. We got a question on our Facebook
page, from Kody Vincent, asking exactly
what I've been wondering since that crappy
Superman: Quest for Peace movie.
He wants to know if we can launch nuclear
waste into the sun.
I love this idea, Kody. Seriously, thanks
for asking. The sun's life giving heat
and light are a result of a constant
nuclear fusion reaction. If we were able
to safely send the nuclear material
towards the sun, it would burn up.
Honestly, it would never even come close to the sun;
It would burn up long before it got there. But that's not
the point. Can we shoot it at the sun?
Sure! Will we? No!
When you picture nuclear waste,
you probably think of the Simpsons and picture
glowing rods or bubbling green goop.
But nuclear waste is actually an umbrella
term for a bunch of different things. Sure, actual
nuclear rods but also, clothing
and tools used in radioactive areas,
and even spare parts exposed to the radiation.
Of that, only 3% is
high level radioactive material
and that's the only bit we'd be launching.
In 1999, the Space Studies Institute
looked at the space disposal of high level
material. According to their assessment,
by 2020, there will
be over 77,000 lbs
of spent nuclear fuel rods
alone on earth. Space access is
expensive at thousands of dollars a pound,
so it's a bit prohibitive cost wise.
Even if money were no object, space
technology has only existed for a little while, and
it's not perfect. NASA's missions do
fail occasionally. Go search for the Orbiting
Carbon Observatory. It crashed
into the ocean, like 17 minutes
after takeoff. That's real crappy if it's a satellite.
It's horrendous if it's
high level nuclear material. And so far, we have
not even scratched the surface of the
problems with this idea, which makes me kind of sad,
because I was excited about it. Not only would we have
to get into space safely, we'd have to cancel
the orbital velocity of the earth.
Earth is moving real fast, you guys,
and though the sun is big, it's not
so big that we couldn't miss if we
shot at it. The amount of energy
that it would take to cancel out Earth's
orbital velocity and then aim for the sun
would be astronomically high. We'd
be better off using the rocket engines
to kill it with fire once we
got it into space. Maybe if we had a
Superman who could safely transport
nuclear material directly into the sun, sure. Maybe.
But how much do you trust a guy with underwear
on the outside of his pants? How do
you feel about this? Betrayed? Relieved?
Explore your thoughts in the comments, just down
here, and make sure that you subscribe for
all of your science therapy. We will see you next
time on DNews.